harry was back in the clinic for the
third time that month the last two times
multiple blood tests came back normal
but he was concerned and as a medical
student it was my job to figure out why
dr. my blood pressure was up over 133
times this week
Harry's stress can do that it's normal
doctor my sleep cycles
I was only in REM 20% of the night Harry
that's actually the definition of a
perfect sleep but doctor these aches and
pains
what if it's lupus what if it's familial
Mediterranean fever I had never even
heard a familial Mediterranean fever
Harry tracked every piece of data
imaginable from activity level mood
swings caloric intake all using digital
health tools
Harry was no idiot he ran a successful
small company and yet in his quest
towards physical perfection he seemed to
be suffering from an overabundance of
data we have unleashed the most powerful
tool in medicine to date the digitally
empowered patient these patients have
long been searching the internet for
their diseases but now thanks to the
boom of mobile health technology they
are equipped with an arsenal of over
30,000 mobile health apps and 115
wearable sensors there is an app to tell
you that the flu is nearby and another
that will display your heart's
electrical activity on your smartphone
in real time these tools can help
motivate patients to make healthier
choices and may be able to reduce the
two trillion dollars our nation spends
every year on preventable chronic
disease these tools can place an
informed patient at the very center of
the health care system and thereby
increase the odds of an accurate
diagnosis and decrease the odds of
medical mistakes but what happens when a
layperson
becomes overwhelmed by information about
his body the closest analogy I can think
of is medical school where a layperson
is transformed into a medical expert
there's an old joke that when you enter
medical school you begin to contract the
zees of the day this was written about
in the medical literature as early as
the 1960s they called it medical student
Titus I remember a day during my first
year of medical school I was in an
ultrasound class imagine it you were in
a darkroom
your tender underbelly is exposed and
for the first time in your life you have
a unique opportunity to peer inside
yourself at one point I became extremely
anxious because I was convinced that a
certain dark spot on the screen was
cancer and it wasn't until the
instructor returned to reassure me that
it was just my kidney that I was able to
relax
I had these fears because I was
acquiring new information about my body
without the medical context to go with
it but of course that was the whole
point of medical school I was benefiting
by working with mentors who had years of
experience separating the truly sick
from the worried well but patients like
Harry don't have access to that will
these tools create a nation of
hypochondriacs psychosomatic conditions
caused real suffering and the resulting
stress can lead to real physical disease
and what about on the other end of the
spectrum what about patients who become
overly confident and there are a host of
other concerns
what who owns the data who is legally
responsible when disease is uncovered
and what about security last year at a
conference a benevolent hackers showed
that it was possible to hack an insulin
pump from 300 feet away to deliver a
lethal dose of insulin so what should we
do these issues are being debated in
Congress as we speak as patients and as
consumers should we rely solely on the
US Food and Drug Administration to
police this industry it's a big job and
they're pretty far away what about as
the Silicon Valley community of
investors entrepreneurs programmers and
health tech I think maybe we should take
on some of this responsibility upon
ourselves physicians at the beginning of
their training all solemnly take the
Hippocratic oath which includes the
adage to first do no harm health tech
entrepreneurs are never asked to do the
same I
to offer three practical strategies
which can help the health tech
entrepreneur protect patients and do no
harm
strategy 1 synthesize the data
Healthcare suffers from information
chaos patients and physicians must
navigate through erroneous conflicting
missing information they just want to
know how the patient is doing poorly ok
or whoa red so show them red yellow
green keep it simple reduce push
notifications strategy to empower the
patient providing personal health data
without some sort of analysis and
actionable results can be almost
inhumane even something as simple as
providing common causes for common
symptoms can reduce anxiety what's a
common cause for racing heartbeat
caffeine what's a common cause for
twitchy muscles caffeine stress mineral
imbalance and most importantly strategy
3 integrate the expert sometimes
patients cannot or should not be
reassured by a product silk the famous
Silicon Valley venture capitalist Vinod
Khosla believes that health technology
will drastically drastically reduce or
even eliminate the need for physicians
but I disagree I think people will
always want access to the experience the
medical context and frankly the human
element that health care professionals
provide and with technology their power
to heal is even greater and yet this is
the most challenging of the three why
because large electronic medical record
companies keep their digital platforms
mostly closed in part to protect profits
that means that the makers of the health
apps cannot seamlessly integrate into
the medical record systems that the
physicians look at and that means that
the physicians and the patients cannot
easily work together simply because
their tools do not talk to one another
this is the single biggest problem in
health technology and it needs to change
as consumers as patients as physicians
as investors we can put pressure on both
the little health technology
companies as well as the large medical
record companies to integrate their
systems and we can do that through
conversations through advocacy and
through our purchasing decisions health
technology will be at the center of
hundreds of millions of medical
decisions going forward I am asking the
health tech entrepreneur to take on the
role of healer and take on the
Hippocratic oath to do no harm we should
be using business to benefit patients
rather than using patients to benefit
business these businesses should go
beyond providing data they should build
products that truly enhance their
customers well-being products that
provide synthesized actionable data that
both empower the patient and integrate
the expert into a cohesive system these
are the products that will be rewarded
in the marketplace thank you
you